Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner, so I want to share a
middle video on understanding emotions, role, and cancer. We could say emotions, role
in any disease. And this could be a series of
100 hours of videos taught by people that are a lot smarter than I am.
But I want to touch on some things because I think this is a piece that
we fail to investigate.
It ourselves because I think if we are honest with ourselves, sometimes we don't want to or we're
fearful of really getting honest with ourselves. So when we look at causes for cancer, causes
for diseases, one of the things that we tend to shine away from is dealing with this emotional
piece. Some people are better at it. Some people are better at being open and understanding that
maybe my breast cancer is tied to a bad relationship that I had in the past. Or maybe my breast
cancer, my liver cancer is tied to some anger that I've held inside me. And then some people are
afraid to deal with that and think that they might have to go through years of counseling to
deal with that. Sometimes that might be necessary. But we have to address this piece of what
emotions do to us and that they can be at least a participating piece in any disease.
So let's just touch on that. I'm going to give some examples to help us understand that.
Organs can be tied to different emotions. There's many different philosophies out there. Some
Chinese philosophies that ties a specific organ to emotions. It's been well known that anger
tends to weaken the liver and liver problems can be stemmed from from hidden or bottled up
anger. Fear affects the kidney stress weakens the brain in heart anxiety and grief affects the
lungs worry could affect the stomach. We could go on and on and there's many different examples
that we can think of with this. But the real tie to this has to do with how our brain processes
events. So as events are experienced, they are held in the brain in our memory centers and we're
just beginning from a neurological standpoint to understand the importance of the temporal lobe
in holding long-term memories at a deep part of the archaeocortex called the amygdala that holds
it's believed to be their very emotionally tied memories. So memories that have a strong
emotion tied to them. Maybe when we were abused as a child or when we went through a physical abuse
or a rape or emotional scar that we had, those emotions can be held in that deep part of the
brain called the amygdala that can be end up coming out later in life as a knee jerk response to
different things and we don't understand why we respond that way but it has to do with a past
event in our life. This is where post-traumatic stress disorder comes from and it's held in there
where you see a soldier that was in battle years ago still responds to fireworks in a negative way
because that fear response is held in the amygdala and it fires off with anything. Similar
will will re-enact that event in their memory centers subconsciously. So it is maybe on a lesser
degree in so many things in our life and it's best if we can address those especially if we're dealing
with a disease or a cancer or something we need to start asking some tougher questions. There's
many different techniques out there what is this technique called any t-dural emotional technique and
this is a sheet I'm sorry it's not very clear on the slide here of some different emotions that are
tied to different organs the stomach spleen in the pancreas here are interconnected a person with
stomach issues could have any of these motions that are tied to the stomach and there's many more this
is just this technique and this is a very simplified version of this but let's say I have a stomach
cancer is it because I am overly sympathetic is it because I'm wholly disgusted emotionally is it
because I have an expanded importance of self is it because I have some obsessive compulsive ideas
in my life is it because I have some egotistic issues narcissistic issues many of these you'll notice
are opposite from one another so despair maybe totally different than obsession or egotistic or
narcissistic nervousness stifled live life through others overly concerned hopelessness lack of control
over events worried distrust low self-esteem very opposite things here so a person could have an
event take place in their life that then has shaped their future decisions and if that is a deep
seated in our mental structure it can affect that organ now in no way shape or form are we saying
anybody with stomach cancer has to have these emotions and we'll go over that and understanding that
we can use charts like this to help us understand our emotions but I think there's even a better way to
look at our organs and emotions and that is to understand the physiology of each organ so that's
my first step in this is to understand the general function of an affected organ we could go back to
a chart like this and and use the stomach well what does the stomach do the stomach holds things that
you have ingested well think of that from a physiological standpoint emotions that are ingested
are are similar to food that's ingested and if we're holding on to emotions that are ingested
and they're not going past that to be digested and to be absorbed and to be dealt with and to be
broken out and to be changed into something that's useful and we're holding it in our stomach it's
going to cause stomach problems so if I'm dealing with a physical stomach problem we could
understand that from an emotional standpoint am I unable to process different emotions
and because I'm unable to process different emotions maybe because of the childhood experience
then I could end up with stomach problems same thing with the pancreas understand the physiology of
the pancreas what is the pancreas to the pancreas makes insulin in order to to utilize sugar and to
utilize good things in my life if I'm unable to process good things in my life and I see things
through a cloudy lens quite often I could end up with pancreatic problems pancreas also makes
digestive enzymes so it's part of the whole digestive and large intestine example I'll give you an
example of a of a person that I know who has a large intestine issues well one of that that
issue with larger intestine is he had to start facing some things that he was he was unable to because
of past events in his life to basically discharge waste is that what the larger intestine does
so the larger intestine holds and discharges waste and if you can't get rid of waste in your life because
of some religious point of view that was put in your life that you have to be the good person all the
time and you could never you could never call maybe someone in your life bad or you could you can't
make a judgment and say that this person in my life is not good for me so that I have to keep
everybody in my life and I don't want to be the bad person and I don't want to get rid of that person
of my life because oh my goodness god forbid that would not be holy then you're going to be more
prone to intestinal problems large intestine pancreatic same kind of thing that's supposed to be
making digestive enzymes to break down waste and help get rid of it and help utilize that but when
we come from a spiritual perspective or I should say a religious perspective that we can't make
judgments in our life and we have to just accept everything in our life and we can't get rid of
bad things or bad people or toxic people in our life then we are going to be more prone to diseases
of those organs so when we understand some of the function the general physiology of the organ
then we can understand a little bit better and start working through some of those processes of
maybe why that happened in my in this organ maybe that's why this disease happened in this organ
another perfect example is I think it was Carolyn Mase that wrote a large section of one of her books
The Molecules of Emotions I believe in that book about how she believed it's in other people's
writings as well that breast cancer is tied in the majority of women with breast cancer
have had an emotional wound from someone they love because you look at the purpose of the breast
is to give to your baby it's to feed and nurture your baby you also give your breasts sexually to your
partner so if you've been hurt by a partner or you've been hurt by a child you're more apt to have
a disease in the breast just like my previous example if you're unable to get rid of
wasted your life whether it be things or whether it be toxic individuals because of
maybe a familial you heard your mother say you shouldn't do that your whole life and you
should be nice to everybody and dare you say that this person doesn't good for you well then you're
more apt to have a disease in that organ so if you understand the physiology of that organ you
can start asking tough questions and that's my second point you have to start asking yourself tough
questions because it's not it's not somebody else's fault we're not here to blame our mother
or blame a spouse even though we might have been a victim in the situation maybe you were abused by
you know someone you loved and you were a true victim in the situation we don't want to
relive that victim hood again you're out of that situation we don't want to stay a victim we want
to acknowledge it and we want to say what was nine role in this and maybe I was an innocent child
at six years old where this took place but then I could I'm not a child anymore what's my role in
moving forward out of this now so we want to ask ourselves tough questions and that okay this is what
happened I could deal with it I could understand my piece of this and now I know understand how I'm
choosing to move forward out of this now if we don't make that choice to move out of this and we're
going to stay as a victim even though it might have been a six-year-old child when it happened
then we could never move out of that and be a victor in a situation thirdly we want to be as
critical of our own behavior as others as I said you may have been a six-year-old victim in the
situation but you're not six years old anymore and when we turned 18 20 years old we have to start
taking that adult throw and moving on with our life and you might have chosen to stay in that
relationship way too long that was abusive you may have chosen to not get rid of that toxic waste
for way too long but it's okay it's watered into the bridge it is what it is and it may have led to
the situation that you're dealing with right now but now you have to say where was my role in this how do
I need to change to move forward out of this it be as critical of my behavior and what I may have done
in this game that I share at least a piece of responsibility with that and the next one is to admit
that through this this these incidents in my life we've chosen certain games to play and we
whatever it is in life we've chosen certain games to play and what would be example of us you know
I'll be as straightforward and honest as possible I'm a doctor why did I choose to be a doctor
because I had to feel like I have to to solve everybody's problem is it's my own messiah complex
that I need to to help other people in order to feel good about myself if that is true I have to admit
those things there's some truth to that I think there's a truth to anybody that's helping anybody else
that we have a little bit of a messiah complex and we have to remember that to we serve a jealous God
and there's only one messiah and I have to admit to that part of the game of life that I'm playing
in order for my healing to take place as well so we're all playing games we all are that's life
we have to admit to some of those games that are destructive to others and destructive to ourselves
and take responsible actions to change that and understand that game that life is a game you can choose
to change the rules you can choose to well I'm not going to do that anymore and it may change
relationships that you have that are unhealthy that it may change relationships that you have
right now that are healthy but as you change who you are and how you play the game of life
some people may not fully understand you and you have to understand that and help them work
through those changes in you because you don't want to just be a jerk and lose all your relationships
unless the relationship that you're losing wasn't a healthy one and you need to lose it so
understand that you have made the rules in your game and you can change those rules you just have
to make that decision to change those rules and have the courage to do so and lastly that understand
that it's a process it's not going to be easy and it's not going to be overnight and that's what life
is and God is a forgiving and merciful God and his mercies are new every single day thank goodness
and I'm going to mess up again tomorrow and I'm going to fall back into that game that I've always
played because I have that stuck in my amygdala and those those remembrances that I have was a child
that brought me to the position that I'm at right now are not going to be easily erased but as we look
at it we take start taking responsibility for ourselves and we stop being the victim and as we may have
to get professional counseling and start working through some of these things we have to start
dealing with this because there are multiple reasons is we're digging to find the cause of your
cancer and yes it may be a pesticide in your large intestine that caused your cancer why did that
pesticide stay there you have to look at that emotional piece too maybe that pesticide stay there because
that my emotions are stuck there and I'm unable to get rid of things in my life my that would be
a dogmatic position right there that religious position that I can't let somebody go and let things
go that I can't be flexible and that it's that I'm a bad person if I say that that another person
or another at a relationship is unhealthy for me and I need to deal with that and you need to
may need to get counseling for that and you may need to work through that with some people that you
love but you have to have the courage to do so and all I'm asking in this little video is that you
start looking at some things more critically looking at your disease more critically seeing what
God is trying to teach you through this because he's this is not a surprise for him
and that that that becomes your prayer Lord what are you trying to teach me through this
to it's for my my best so show me how to change show me what I need to change show me
where I haven't been bringing you the glory that I should be bringing you
and teach me how to do that that's what I'm asking your prayer to be go through these steps
and I think you'll find them helpful and we could talk more about this all those emotions all your
emotions are good it's when we get stuck in a certain situation when we maybe for moods of our past
maybe from learned behavior that wasn't healthy that it could cause a lot of problems so
that's your challenge for today and I hope that you can work through that and talk to me if you need
thanks a bunch